Today's Jenna's big move into her
apartment and we've gotta uhh.. get this TV
somehow into my car because I don't think it's gonna fit in her car
this is the first big purchase that
I bought in Los Angeles.. "What?"
TV.. "Oh, thanks.. passing on that legacy.."
We've got the air mattress here
Jenna here, TV here
It was as actually pretty easy to get in, all things considered
considering what it took to get that to
my house and    JENNA: Considering our poor planning
LEFT
[moving sound] - [singing] TURN DOWN FOR WHAT!!
It came with FREE toilet paper
FREE TP! Let's see how it flushes
Let's see how this toilet flushes
Okay.. uhhh, alright
[flushes] looks great
Guys, I'm so excited so Tuesday this
Tuesday
coming up what October 28th "Yes" So Steak n Shake is finally opening
I'm so excited my
this was the only way that I survived
college but they cooked all my food for
me
It's gonna be right there and it's right here only
got you know how we like our you are
opening hit a couple
I believe would like to see what a
quality
I kinda wanna have like to meet up H
sorta things didn't happen to be in the
lineup
on Tuesday's ruling in the morning-ish
please come here
third Street I wanna be your guide
okay
guiding your head while you can
we have a company right here
level
now you're right lou levin gonna be here
but I mean if this is my calls are going
to be no
fully credible I am still time top
agenda but I'm on Twitter and Instagram
soul not that's not how ya know
only got done it's right here your
opinion on it love you too
goodnight
faith by this
great what good
fear for the grand opening yeah I'm very
good overnight certainty their training
new employees it looks like he was
receding greeted you
Angelina yeah accomplices
but
my with delivered located really the
picture
go make them look
we greenside peace
comment
now
Demi Moore lucky please
I'll be here 900
I go
we just made it to lurk
the pumpkin patch no guest may be
photographed without okay let's okay
because it's just us welcome to the
palms pumping pumping
pony rides I'm eating honey haven't gone
no money
%uh the jump in pumpkin no the slide is
a Windows seven day
I we have to get some glowsticks
we have 20 cool bracelet where that he's
gonna miss all the fun John
the animals at all oh my gosh honey it
had
look at you guys have any time you would
battered chicken
that the chicken if the check in time
that's trying to get the shot
these are perfect yeah
look at them so little for more than
just maybe the complementary means
and so shooting on 120 frames a second
weapon Rocklin pumpkin not only
you bright and early I guess because a
lot we got up with the GoPro
attack on how heavy is this pretty
yeah but I'll just take a ride to the
final frontier
good is he likely
Monday a uphold it around banja
I'm a real kiss from the Honduras ft
on her left hip on break below I have
never won t shirt
to I love in the team ID letters I can't
get out
on Armada take credit cards well
and the blood